this guy doesn't need to develop he
doesn't need to move to develop these
guys are in their typical position
something tells me this might be a
pretty good start
hmm what's unprotected nothing
everything is defended from this initial
position actually except for this guy
but he can't be captured too quickly
it's the a B G and H pawns that you need
to worry about the most if they're
unprotected okay maybe this orally not
because the Queen eventually be hitting
it as soon as this pawn moves this is a
likely move for black let the Queen out
why not go with this one to start there
a good reason not to go with that
well
I'm not seeing it so let's go here Oh
copycat just playing the copycat game I
see how it is
well now it's one or two squares with
this pawn my queen could already come
out what does this Knight want to do
let's get him here are they gonna copy
again quit your copying okay maybe this
and then Bishop here maybe this
before playing this pond up I might be
concerned a little bit about a queen or
a bishop maybe coming over here to give
a check if I play here right away I
could always block if I just keep it
still sitting I always block a potential
check on this short diagonal so maybe
retain this bishops options in other
words what about g3 Bishop g2 mmm what
else is my bishop thinking about
probably nothing else well what's wrong
with it
g3 Bishop g2 my knight I'm torn between
one of these two maybe I'll end up
playing d4 though all right let's see
might as well swing the bat completely
around here no checks wings g3 Bishop g2
follow-through so let's go there is
Bishop move here but I could play this
no worries
ah but that's a worry why did I see this
I was already talking about it being a
weak point I should be okay though did I
have this knight move that was silly why
wasn't I maybe considering that I did
that in previous games that identifying
the weak point and then trying to go
after like a maniac but just in the nick
of time I'm there to now have my rook
defend here because he's no longer
reliable and actually this is an
incredibly annoying pin and I want to
get out of it real soon I don't like it
oh this is a pain this is a pain right
here I don't want to be in this pin can
I just get out of this pin please what a
pain that Bishop is a knight here I'm
giving up a very valuable bishop
see right here
chop-chop and my night could go
elsewhere I couldn't be coming under an
attack Dolph I would give this guy up I
don't like that it's so awkward to
defend my night with the rook and then
get my Queen out and to move my knight
ah maybe oh well maybe there's something
to this actually maybe I could afford
double-deep Hans I afford to have double
D pawns here let's see Queen B to take
stakes I could get this move in right
I'm gonna try for it I do have to be a
bit concerned about maybe the bishop
getting here now it's not gonna be
playing there so let's go clean here and
I'm really I just want my knight next
where's he gonna move e5 seems pretty
good
I think things turned out to be okay now
is black gonna kill the knight on d3
there's no way to clamp down on the d4
square with e5 I have more control over
it in black this night I could kick him
away whenever I want right now he's not
a bother let's get some trades in I'm on
that pawn
f7 there's a castle and the roof defends
now do I take with my knight or my queen
I like taking with my queen and then I'm
going to recapture with my bishop and
I'm not sure why I keep doing this why
am I so reluctant to give up my
light-square bishop maybe it is okay to
take with my knight at this point
actually I'm not I want to get in d3
maybe position my knight on this square
interesting starts to look like a normal
chess position doesn't it looks like
that how about I back my bishop up well
I don't know what do you do here this is
uh this is some interesting structure
right here I mean well I mean it's it's
typical out of a regular chess position
so did I push here
d6 I might lose a pawn or something it's
just develop I really don't know it's
probably gonna be d6 I guess and if my
bishop needs to retreat I'll go to this
square B - not a one just run the risk
of an eventual back rank sort of thing
if these rooks leave Bishop could get
picked off on any one so if it's gonna
retreat go here not here just in the way
the rook d6 Bishop b2 what is black
going to do maybe similar rook after D
eight where are even with time here
now what I don't know this is a pretty
equal position Oh
now something changes though this is a
big decision isn't it hmm my night I
want to get my night to d5 so it's much
safer to have my bishop my LightSquared
bishop no longer on the board if I can
be assured of lüt as long as I could be
assured that the Queen's are off the
board without the bishop and if the
Queen's are on the board I might be
coming under an attack but not here I'd
like to get this night off of the board
and then sit my night right here on d5
that's actually dropping material epon
it's a problem less than a minute less
time you have the more mistakes you make
that was a problem right there
rook up lateral movement preparing to
double preparing B for my knight has a
decent amount of flexibility there is no
good
Bishop move that's gonna be annoying to
me this is unprotected okay now it's
being hit and I should have actually
done something about that okay well I
was forgetting that this is unprotected
play here and as a follow-up I think
this is a good idea just securing my
Knights position stopping f5 and now I
want to break at this my rooks don't
want to just be sitting on a half-open
file for black wants to be peeled open
so let's go peel that file right open
and now on the defensive is black Bishop
is dropped and now there are main
threats rook takes this is bad no time
though to figure it out it's a back
rancor okay
good game let's back up I think that
that was really even its until up just
before that d5 move I would not be
surprised at all if the computer was
really really close to just a goose egg
with the evaluation okay so this I don't
know why wasn't I referenced this early
on that it's unprotected I said it
wasn't as accessible as the a B G and H
puns but well I came into play didn't it
I was there fortunately in the nick of
time right here
my d3 to defend and castle since I can't
rely upon that Knight anymore
I wonder if there's something you could
be doing with like coming after my King
h5h for is uh I think a bit of a concern
to me this your Bishop really has me in
a not so I don't know like was their way
to do better like could you have
actually taken the night and I don't
know about that you are giving up a
valuable piece a valuable Bishop and
then I could undo button get my other
deep on then rolling don't know I'm
struggling to make suggestions here
because I think the moves that black was
running with are good pressure on me and
I'm having to just untangle myself but
I'm not it's not a case of untangling
myself and then all of a sudden I become
better
it's okay both bishops get kicked away
and I mean look at look at this actually
right here look at this position where
are their weaknesses for either side I
know there's there's nothing going on
really here not until this move is
played do I start to see some hope for
maybe some positional grip looking again
at d5 but uh you know what do i do like
even right here I'm not sure I think
it's an even position I don't know I
don't have anything great to I be adding
to this game I thought it I thought it
was played well I mean towards the end
okay the pawn push I could do something
other than that good